thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a righteous
wild ride with Stevo we've got Adam
DeVine who is frankly on fire right now
plus he's been all over the news because
there was an actual murder at his
neighbor's house during a high-stakes
poker game and he's been freaking out
because the media has the impression
that he witnessed the murder and now he
thinks he might be a target for the
murder it's all very real very juicy
there are a lot of private parts in this
conversation plus like stuff that I
couldn't even believe he revealed about
his latest interactions with Zac Efron
Danny McBride I mean it is high power
and totally intense so let's get into it
yeah be careful with your head on the
way of it watch your feet
watch my head watch my feet torso what's
up man how's it going good to see you
good to see you yeah brother yeah man
Dad this is a treat man it's not that
often where I interview somebody and I'm
actually just a complete Die Hard fan of
[__] thanks
gemstones is so [__] badass thanks
man yeah and we're back baby
it's uh the fun has started once again
and that's what we're promoting here
uh that and uh the Outlaws the movie I
have coming out uh on the seventh okay
got it yeah
our air conditioning
we've got this it's pretty cool man did
you see the air conditioning outside of
the van in the front I did it's just
that's like a [__] full-on man
uh we actually were recording a podcast
the other day and the cops made us open
up the door to show that we weren't
cooking meth in here or something oh
really
I like Breaking Bad has it it influenced
enough people that they're like
everyone's cooking meth yeah okay
um do you have a color
that was actually my favorite color as a
kid and then people would kids other
kids would make fun of me and be like
you like purple and I'm like it's
midnight blue I'm like it's midnight
blue [__] I had a dino bike and uh and
every kid's like that's [__] purple
and I'm like no [__] purple's just lame
to like yeah I guess all right let's
dive into it I got uh 419
um you know what I might even be
actually one minute away man
yeah well it's a regular amount of pro
worth it
all right here we go
ladies and gentlemen Adam DeVine In the
Flesh what's up man dude it's great man
I'm doing great dudes great to have you
yeah thanks for having me
um I uh
I'm thrilled to show you the van because
you were I assume I've never been in it
it's nice to see this is a sick setup
you have here yeah thanks man it's
awfully uh convenient to be able to
bring the the podcast to the guest bring
the studio to the guest and I I it's
nice that uh I had you park on the side
of a cliff which is
we are ready to slide right off right
now yeah emergency brake is on good good
good they said you had police activity
at your house all week yeah dude someone
was murdered across the street from my
house yeah that was what I was gonna ask
you I heard you murdered your neighbor
but it wasn't me uh yeah it was I don't
know it was like they have like poker
games over there and I don't know
exactly what happened but uh yeah
there's a murder and then I talked about
it on our podcast and and uh this is
important the podcast I do with the Box
guys and and then the headline was Adam
DeVine and wife witnessed murder and I'm
like that's not what happened uh and
look like I don't want any psychopath
out there being like they witnessed it
so um so yeah we did we did not see it
if the the killer watches this
um I saw you tweeted that and and there
I could read in the text of the Tweet
like that there's some manic energy yeah
uh you don't hear anything no we weren't
even home we weren't even at home when
it happened but it was allegedly yeah uh
no we weren't but the next day there was
like uh
like my friends and [__] know where I
live and then it says like the the like
39 year old man murdered in the
Hollywood Hills and then it shows a
photo of my neighborhood and my friends
are like Adam's 39 he lives right there
they think I was murdered so I woke up
to like 15 texts being like dude are you
alive like hey homie are you dead and
they they haven't caught anybody not as
far as I know the police activity like
it continues as far as I know yeah I
mean they don't really keep you up to
date the police you know they're not
what does that do your property value
are you worried about that does it go up
my wife was like we have to sell the
house today and I'm like
we'll wait it out yeah I'm like this is
the Hollywood Hills man people people
are getting shot people come and go off
yeah so yeah if anything in the
Hollywood Hills that might bump up the
value yeah that's right
High six poker games is kind of cool
cool yeah yeah what was that movie where
all those people got murdered off Laurel
Canyon uh Wonderland yeah that's pretty
close to here kinda kind of that was sad
that involved the John Holmes the guy
with like the biggest wiener yeah yeah I
don't know the wiener size of who is
involved with this right so yeah
yeah
fortunately everybody knows our wieners
are the size of our wieners yeah do we
know how many millions of Americans saw
your wiener on Netflix oh they told they
didn't tell us like exact numbers my
managers said they did he was like it's
70 million and I'm like no one ever told
me that number but uh a ton dozens of
Millions for sure I can absolutely
attest that when that movie came out
it's all I heard about everywhere I went
yeah some things you do move the needles
some things do not and that thing like
turns out and you know this if you show
your dick or and or butthole
people will talk about it were you uh
were you nervous about doing a scene
having to show your dick I wasn't dude
because uh it's in the movie game over
man and people are like
but uh yeah we did a movie and you were
cool enough to be in it thank you for
doing it yeah I loved it it uh
no because I wrote we wrote the movie it
took so long for it to get made that we
that was like one of the first when we
were like pitching ideas for the movie
that was one of the first ideas so this
the scene is that the hotel's getting
taken over by terrorists and we're
housekeepers and we're like hiding in a
room and the terrorists are kicking down
doors and they're coming and they're
like where should we hide what should we
do and then I whip off my belt and I go
I've got an idea and I go snap snap and
the audience doesn't know what that
means and then cut to the the terrorists
come in they've got their guns drawn and
then they open up the closet door and
I'm hanging there on my neck with my
dick limp dick in my hand uh autorada
myself yeah and uh super fun
inherently a very funny scene and uh so
no I wasn't really that that nervous I
don't get nervous about [__] like that
yeah yeah dude it's Epic Man
um and and I was at the premiere where
your mom got to see that scene yeah for
the first time I was just uh yeah I was
uh I was just talking with them right
before I pulled up but uh my mom like
while the scene was happening like my
sister was there like my sister doesn't
want to see my dick like you know what I
mean so my sister was like I I told her
I was like hey uh it this this is the
scene divert your eyes if you don't want
to see it and I told my mom and her and
my my sister was like the whole time
like you know not looking and then uh my
mom doesn't divert her eyes like it's
like hmm and then grabs my leg and it's
like I'm so proud of you don't tell me
how proud she is like while my dick is
flapping about and then we get in a
full-on fight scene and my dick's off
for like
four or five minutes straight within and
I get like solar plex kicked in the
chest and I like flip Head Over Heels so
like if you pause it I think you could
see my butthole or at least two points
do my bottle so it's um
during jackass your sister and your
niece while you're they saw my butthole
yeah loud and clearer
that was uncomfortable for me too yeah
whatever yeah it's all good man most
butthole they look the same you know the
buttholes are a butthole we did have a
butthole beauty pageant in Cancun oh did
you who won no no buttholes oh really
yeah some of them look like uh the a
tied off balloon yeah yeah yeah
and some are probably wildly hairy and
yeah it was interesting when I was on uh
uh Bobby Lee and Andrew Santino's bad
Friends Podcast I mentioned that and
they were they just both popped up
turned around and just spread their butt
cheeks so wide and did they yeah it was
a while they bared their puddles like
like what Santino did too because I know
that I know Bobby will show his butthole
yeah
Santina did too and they both had like
impressive I mean clearly they're proud
of him yeah
[Applause]
I mean dude it was a toss-up they were
both like immaculate yeah and tight and
just just beautiful beautiful yeah yeah
mine admittedly not the best looking
yeah yeah
okay dude I'm gonna tell you I got
invited to
um uh host the the main stage of the
Gathering of the Juggalos then the the
congrats the the famous
dude your career's really blossoming
the famous Insane Clown Posse and uh
while I was on stage and you know I come
out and introduce a band called
introducible and while I was out there
the audience was just screaming show us
your butthole and I was confused by this
you know because I came up and one of
the guys from ICP Shaggy chewed up I was
like man they're like they've been
screaming show us your butthole he goes
oh yeah they mean it they want to see it
so I'm like I'm like who am I to yeah
Dash their dreams I need money to be
there yeah it was the Dark Carnival of
the souls they might as well see your
dark carnival right so I went out there
and spread them as wide as I possibly
could and the next day the photos
started popping up yeah and my my
cavernous butthole is an absolute Legend
now nice dude congrats I think it's like
it was the lighting it was it hit just
right the clouds parted yeah it looked
like it was like a gaping [__] but
like when we show your butthole on the
pre-show like it doesn't look like that
at all right I mean yeah he gave it out
for the
so
um I don't know if you had started your
podcast when we spoke to you last yeah I
can't remember if we did or not I mean
like I remember it was because of the
pandemic you guys started yeah that's
right yeah we were like
we were just like we got to do something
and we want to stay in touch and we're
like you know we're really good friends
but you know how guy friends are like
you could just go like five years
without talking to like your best friend
and then you're like oh hey uh so I was
like let's I don't know if it's my idea
whose idea it was but we were just like
let's uh let's start a podcast so we
have a reason to talk every week
you never need a reason to tell you how
much I love my bed from Helix sleep
that's right and here I am in London
England with this crazy new dog that I
rescued from a local shelter I'm
fostering it it's attacking everybody
and I'm not even worried about it bigger
problem is that I'm sleeping on a bed in
a hotel that didn't come from Helix
sleep and that's just too bad but you
don't have to endure that you can go to
Helix
sleep.com slash Stevo and enjoy up to
350 off any mattress plus get two free
pillows and you know what this mattress
is going to be perfect for you because
they have a two-minute quiz that you
take when you get to the website and it
matches you up with the perfect mattress
for you and your partner if you sleep in
bed as a couple it's the time to get a
brand new mat address that's perfect for
you and the way to do that is to go to
Helix sleep.com slash Stevo again for up
to 350 off of any mattress plus two free
pillows get rid of that disgusting old
mattress and get a new one from Helix
sleep now let's get back to it yeah and
um how many episodes are you in I think
we're like 130 or 140 something like
that yeah we've just been churning and
burning baby it's really fun I love
doing it yeah and the fact that anyone
listens I'm like this is like it's so
fun to like be out and about because
when you like do a movie or you have a
TV show you think people are watching
because you're like people are telling
you like this many people are watching
or you know
so I'm always so amazed at like when I'm
out at a restaurant or with specifically
it's valet guys I feel like every ballet
every ballet guy everywhere it's just
like TIR nation which is this is
important yeah
um I mean dude it's fascinating how the
medium of podcasts is so compelling to
some people and what it is it's the the
unedited unfiltered on Raw like they're
they're right there they feel like
they're with you hanging out and um
I I just don't get it but
not for me
some people are like I love it like oh
like uh you know what podcast do you
listen to and I'm like no no
the eclipse of my friends podcast and
things like that but uh yeah I'm kind of
in the same boat I'm like I think it's
people that have uh that have like long
commutes and stuff like anyone that I
know that like has like a hour-long
commute every day they're like yeah I
just listen to podcasts but do you watch
the news anymore or do you watch that
that's political [__] I I am
madly in love with Lester Holt uh the
NBC Nightly News NBC Nightly News I
would say that's a that's one of the
ones where I feel like they're and
whether they are or not I have no idea
but like it's the the Nightly News where
they just come on for one hour and tell
you news that's what I like the best and
it's not like the CNN or the fox or
whatever where they just have to talk
all goddamn day and then dude it's only
20 minutes yeah yeah it's like it's like
a half hour TV show and without
commercials so so it's great but you
know going back to the podcast thing
like I love it I love that we get to
have fascinating conversations with like
famous people on a weekly basis so I
guess it does make sense that people
they're supposed to hang out with me and
and YouTube yeah it's it's fun I love
doing it so big time star man oh yeah
and uh we've got a couple things to
promote for you one of which I know
nothing about you said it's a new movie
yeah it's a new movie It's called The
Outlaws um comes out July 7th it's uh is
incredible dude it's me and and Pierce
Brosnan and Nina Dobrev and Ellen Barkin
Michael Rooker
um it's Michael Rooker wow he played
Henry the the portrait of a serial
killer is that right is that right I I
and he was in Days of Thunder Man he was
like the villain in Days of Thunder
opposite Tom Cruise he's the [__] and
Pierce Brosnan obviously 007 is the man
does he have an accent yeah is it Irish
he's Irish Irish accent yeah and so he
can like twist it to be yeah because I
saw a movie with him when he was doing
an Irish accent like he's pretty good at
it but yeah
so he's an Irish in our movie we're just
like Let It Fly so he says like funny
Irish things he calls me a sheep shagger
uh which is an Irish thing to call uh
people but uh yeah the premise
essentially is like
I'm about to get married to Nina Dobrev
and I've never met their in-laws I've
never even seen photos there's like no
photos of these people they come into
town they're like the coolest
[__] and it's Ellen bark and
Pierce Brosnan and they take me out and
we get drunk I get a tattoo we go
skydiving like all the [__] that I
normally wouldn't do I'm like a straight
lace bank manager guy and I go into work
the next day all hungover and Lil Rel
who's works at the bank with me is like
yo you look like [__] dude it was that
bad made in your in-laws I'm like it was
that good like I just need a nice chill
day uh you know uh where I can relax be
but my in-laws are the [__] click click
there's a gun to my head and my bank is
getting robbed by two people in masks
and as they leave they say something
that leads me to believe that my in-laws
are actually these Infamous Outlaws that
are bank robbers wow yeah so and then uh
and then it's just it starts off and
you're like oh this is just like kind of
a cute rom-com you know I've seen a
movie like this before and then it goes
full-on ape [__] and it's like a big
action movie and we got to do some like
really cool stunts and and like Chase
sequences we gotta destroy a ton of cars
and nice yeah cool skydiving no no movie
Magic yeah yeah so you have to see the
movie to find out if the in-laws are
actually bankrupted
that's not like really The Twist The
Twist because you find that out pretty
early right okay and like like Point
Break campaign Grabber yeah I mean kind
of they they like wear these like crazy
masks and have like a voice disguise
thing uh and but then like we gotta do
like some really really cool stunts like
I drove a uh I drove an armored truck
through a cemetery and like cop cars are
chasing me through the cemetery and I'm
just like plowing over gravestones
headstones and like cop cars are like
hitting the headstones and like flipping
and doing all kinds of crazy [__] it was
really fun cool yeah super cool and
where does that come out Netflix on uh
July 7th so Netflix is back on top huh
like all the news is they're struggling
their stocks hurt everything that's just
going like this yeah yeah yeah they're
doing okay yeah yeah it's like 4X in the
last two months and I'm just killing
myself for selling tours yeah yeah you
uh you're you got a comedy special on
Netflix yeah Best Time Of Our Lives uh
that's on Netflix Game Over man's on
Netflix I got a rom-com called when we
first met on uh on Netflix I love
Netflix dude yeah
I just did uh I like CBS Morning Show
with like Gail King like literally like
two days ago and um and it was awesome
and they were very nice but it was like
all CBS is now Paramount oh and so CBS
is Viacom yes yes so it's all like under
the same umbrella and so I see all this
like Paramount stuff everywhere and I'm
like yeah
they canceled the workholics movie right
we spoke with jurors about that yeah at
some length
um it's it's crazy man like I I get it
if they were worried about the like the
Workaholics brand being kind of America
Centric and not having International
appeal that's fine but why let it get so
far Downstream with the production
schedule like locked in and everybody's
hired and then pulled the plug at the
last minute yeah
it was kind of boned like our crew and
all the people like we'll be fine but it
really sucks for the people that are
down the line that are like the grips
and the electrics and like those guys
were our friends so we hired like mostly
everyone we could get back from
Workaholics and we're like let's just
bring everybody back and people were
canceling other jobs to work come work
with us and then
we it was just like they pulled the rug
out from underneath all of us and it was
it was a writer strike and then the
writers strike happened I was like yeah
[__] man yeah is that TK involved in
Workaholics
our boy yeah Thomas Kellogg Thomas
Kellogg love TK TK's been around us
since we went to college with him wow
that's great dude that I love working
with TK best when I've got like a big
shoot uh TK is just my guide
yeah crazy
um Netflix is definitely being good to
you but
can we talk about HBO or sorry Max oh
yes thank you thank you for clearing
that up contractually I can't talk about
uh yeah
um I mean I I am a rabid fan of the
righteous gemstones are you aware that
that my my lady and I dressed up as
uh
Uncle Billy oh Uncle baby Billy yeah
baby baby Billy yeah when's the last
time you dressed up for Halloween before
that yeah 20 years now I do it every
year now because of locks yeah but uh
but we killed it that's sick like uh we
we killed it yeah and then what is it
Aunt Julie and Jill like uh baby Billy's
girl oh uh
it's so damn good and well her real name
is Valen uh she says she's a fantastic
yeah yeah uh and uh yeah the show's so
damn fun I mean big pride has always
been like a comedy King to me so when he
came and was like yo you want to do this
show with me I was like we had just
gotten done doing Workaholics and it's
been like maybe a year or so afterwards
and I kind of was like I don't want to
do TV for a while I just want to like
make do my own thing do stand up figure
out some movies to do and then when
Danny called I was like yeah of course
I'm not sure I gotta do it and this is
season three coming on yep season three
like the pandemic kind of boned us a
little bit because
um you know no one could shoot anything
and we're about to go shoot season two
when it shut down and then so now we're
only on season three when in fact we
should be on like four or even uh I
think you're getting ready to go shoot
season two when we spoke last yeah
season two came out my my girl and I I
mean dude HBO half hour comedies man
like Silicon Valley was that just so
good Curb Your Enthusiasm right
righteous gemstones they do a good job
of like just letting their they hire
good people and then letting them do
what they want to do and yeah not
interfering and I think that's like
that's what Comedy Central used to be
really good at uh and I you know because
they really let us do what we wanted to
do
you know what I want to do I want to be
super healthy look great and start every
morning with a delicious treat and
that's what I do no matter where I am in
the world with ag1 this is the most
delicious comprehensive and convenient
nutritional supplement you can get and
you know what you might have heard me
talk about this before but I just want
you to try it once and tell me if it's
not the most delicious nutritional
supplement you've ever heard of I use
less and less water all the time to mix
it with because I just can't believe how
tasty it is plus not to mention the 75
different vitamins minerals Whole Food
sourced superfoods probiotics adaptogens
I mean this stuff is on top of being so
delicious pretty much the healthiest
thing you can put in your body man and I
put it in my body every morning it's the
first thing I do and that's I'm so happy
and healthy and you can be too if you go
to drink
ag1.com
Stevo if you do that on your first order
you're gonna get five free convenient
travel packs
totally for free Plus
an entire year's supply of vitamin D to
boost your immunity that's totally free
with your first order at drink
ag1.com Stevo and again it's delicious
so jump on this deal
and let's get back to it uh but I think
we we gotta ingest under the wire where
before you know yeah Comedy Central is
not even a
is that still a network I mean I think
it is like yeah it's like nothing's on
it anymore yeah that you even know which
sucks because I'm sure there's some
funny stuff it's crazy yeah um the end
of season two
felt like it was over
yeah Danny he he really wants to he's
like I don't I don't want to be in this
situation where you like
where you know we hope we think we're
coming back people love the show but
he's like I want every season to feel
like a self-contained thing right so
like if that's it you the audience is
like that was great I love that and not
feel like you're left going like well
they didn't finish telling the stories
you know yeah then you got to wait like
nine months for the next one to come out
yeah yeah or or even if you're you're
canceled and you don't come back and
then they're just like going like well
that sucks what happened right it's bad
luck it did Danny's Danny's just the
king he's really oh yeah have you met
him I don't think I've ever met him yeah
he's he's the he's the [__] he's like
just as cool as you want him to be you
know and he lives in North Carolina
South Carolina Charleston she doesn't
really get in the mix too much yeah he
lived here for like 20 years and then
like I think they shot uh Vice
principals which is a show right before
gemstones and they
um they shot in Charleston and he had
like I don't think he'd spend that much
time in Charleston and then shooting
there uh for like they shot for like a
year because they shot two seasons back
to back and he was like I fell in love
with it he said he came back got his
stuff and uh and like 20 families moved
out with him and he just like moved out
with a whole a whole crew of people and
he was like let's just let's start
Hollywood South yeah yeah I love that
man so
um now that is righteous Jim Jones
already airing it is yeah the first two
episodes just came on last Sunday and
then now it'll be uh every Sunday for
the next you know what seven more weeks
or something dude fantastic my girl and
I are not allowed to watch it alone yeah
that's like appointment watching for us
together well that's that's good and
don't do it because that's how
relationships implode over things like
that yeah yeah yeah big time yeah you
could you could lose it all
right yeah same thing with Black Mirror
that's uh we started what God damn this
new season of Black Mirror is good I I
watched the first couple episodes it is
it precisely too and not not the third
yeah you haven't seen the one with Aaron
Paul no not yet I haven't yet how's that
one
I can't talk about it
secret Secrets yeah
um so so you've been married like two
years now
yeah a little not quite two years later
and a half yeah you gotta know yeah no
it's it's it'll be two years in October
yeah
Marissa okay good talk about losing it
all yeah right
uh what's her first thing
uh are you uh planning on having kids
yeah I think so yeah wow that's crazy to
me that's the craziest thing I mean yeah
it is crazy it's crazy to be like it's
growing you know especially like uh
she's like an only child I'm the my
sister my little sister doesn't have
kids so it'll be like the first kid in
like either of our families wow so it's
gonna be it's it'll be a wild ride I'm
sure in my YouTube feed I saw a video
that said don't bring children into the
AI world
what kind of algorithm you got going on
YouTube I don't know but uh
I feel so goddamn scared of the AI stuff
I'm like dude I mean for sure it'll be
weird I bet it's just I bet it's just
gonna be uh humans are just gonna be
lazy sacks of [__] and ai's gonna do
everything for us like I guess that's
what I think is gonna happen or into the
world who knows yeah I'm not as
concerned about like you know AI trying
to wipe out the human race but I just
I'm kind of surprised that there has not
been like a deep fake at least some kind
of a good Scandal you know they're like
oh here's a video of Barack finger in
his butthole
right I mean there could be like and and
how uh when people are embroiled in
scandals that had nobody's pulled the oh
that was a deep fake card dude I think
it's not quite there I think we're like
another six months later and and uh then
there'll be all kinds of [__] okay
things like fake have you seen that they
they're making with a 3D printer edible
chicken like you can just eat chicken
made with a 3D printer is that real bad
it's real it has all the [__] like
ingredients or whatever is in a goddamn
chicken and you cook it and eat it but
it's not like a real chicken it's it's a
3D what do you mean it it all the
ingredients
it's like a clone of a chicken used like
made from a 3D printer yeah so you can
eat it it's edible [__] chicken
well that's tight
you eat it as a vegan and Scott Randolph
believes everything here's on so no
matter what [__] comes through his
Facebook feed he's just
gobbles it up and it is Gospel to him
but did you hear that I did see that
yeah do you believe it yes I did believe
it okay okay
would you eat that as a as a vegan
I'm back to pescetarian so I I have not
eaten Chicken in but it's not in over 15
years
I don't I don't like At first off I
would have to believe that what you're
saying is true yeah to begin with and
then I would have to evaluate it but
will you do you eat like uh like Beyond
burgers and stuff like that I do and and
I I eat it recognizing that it is awful
for me yeah oh yeah that's what's it
made out of whether Beyond burgers are
awful all that stuff is
it's just heavily processed like I know
like the garden fake meat all that fake
chick is just super heavy processed soy
and wheat one time I went to what's
called a colonic hydrotherapy to get a
tube up my butt and like really and you
like that stuff though
yeah to flush it all out and this late
this thing it's coming out through this
clear hose and it's all just this lady's
like what are you eating and I was like
oh I'm totally vegan I eat lots of uh of
uh gardein figures like
problem here and she's pointing to all
this just cloudy oh there's just a green
goo just yeah yeah it was it was she was
like that she was like what we're seeing
coming out of you right here is evidence
that your body does not recognize that
stuff as food you're eating stuff that
your body does not recognize as food Oh
weird
yeah I guess it's like human evolution
like our bodies haven't caught up with
like how we've made things to eat yeah
it's like the Buffalo uh boneless
buffalo wings at yard house that's all
Garden right yeah and I love it I love
it
but I just don't try not to eat it that
much and that's why I went back to
eating Seafood because I just believe
it's healthy for me to eat stuff that my
body recognizes as food yeah I would say
that's probably a safe bet is your body
should recognize it as food yeah yeah
yeah yeah I
curious I'm curious to know as like do
you have one piece of content that
you've posted on the internet that has
wildly outperformed everything else
uh and it's not no not butthole related
it's right already covered all butthole
related topics
um I think uh yeah I guess the the thing
that I posted that I was like I posted
it from the set of righteous gemstones
and and like the 22 year old like little
pa kids that work on the show were like
popping in being like Oh my god dude
perfect was Adam Levine who I have a
name very similar to that guy my name is
Devine his is Levine is you've switched
the D with the L and our names are
switched uh he had like a thing with he
was like texting some girl named Sumner
and uh said like okay I'm gonna name my
baby Sumner after you and uh and it was
like he was having some kind of repair
allegedly allegedly uh and I was getting
this is how [__] up news is is people
are such fools that they just read his
name
it as my name in their heads and were
coming after me being like [__] you Adam
like you cheating on your wife
are you scumbag and the girls being like
I I used to like you what the hell from
Pitch Perfect I thought you were a nice
guy and like hundreds
and I was getting like news like from
like the like literal news organizations
from it was like local like Pittsburgh
News or whatever and being like Adam
DeVine cheats on pregnant wife and I
just like [__] it up they just like
misspelled the name and so I'm just
getting like all this [__] and so
finally I was like I'm not going to
stand for this and so I get online and
I'm on Instagram and I post a photo with
me and my wife
and uh and and I was just like I don't
even know what I said like that's not me
um I'm uh I'm a totally different guy
and a better singer ha you know but my
wife and I are gonna name our future
baby Sumner
and
the internet just went it was just like
I like sent it and then went and did a
scene and when I came back it had like a
hundred thousand plus likes like within
like an hour or less and then all the
little 20 year old uh pas were like what
crazy yeah and I was like this it was so
a nothing thing for me to do but like it
just tapped into that that pop culture
moment yeah it just just broke right
into the news cycle uh-huh viral Banger
yeah it's weird when [__] like like the
murder thing it was like that it was
just like
just takes off and you have no you don't
think it's gonna take off or you have no
idea and then all of a sudden it's like
that's that's what people are talking
about yeah I I was aware that the news
hadn't gotten it all wrong that you were
upset about that and that's why I opted
to say I heard you murdered your name
yeah
Vinnie over here skinny Vinny he uh he
said that your Workaholics Bros were
concerned when you when did the Pitch
Perfect movie
look man I get it it's totally natural
for friends to be concerned about one
another especially if one of them has a
filthy nasty habit then it is time to
ditch and that's why I'm so happy to
tell you this episode is brought to you
by fume and if you go to
tryfume.com and use the promo code Stevo
you're going to get 10 off the journey
pack to start the journey now what's
this all about it's a fume it's a device
that flavors air that you breathe in so
you can trade in dangerous chemicals for
delicious flavored air and this is just
a great way to ditch a bad habit and
replace it with a good habit I've been
giving them out to my friends we're
seeing great results and if you know
it's time for you to drop that filthy
habit then it is time for you to go to
try fume dot com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the promo code
Stevo to get 10 off of your journey pack
your journey to being healthier and
happier starts now at tryfume.com with
the promo code Stevo now let's get back
to it that it was going to
uh oh yeah I I saw that Blake not all of
them but Blake said Blake specifically
it was a really bad idea Blake's sipping
on some haterade I think
it was
super early on during the Pitch Perfect
uh the workholic stays and it was like I
think we were shooting season two or we
were and we were like finishing up
writing season two or something like
that and I got the offer to be in this
movie and it's Pitch Perfect and it's
not a baseball movie it is a singing
movie and I was like
the script I thought was funny and I was
like let me see if my guys think it's
funny and so I give it to blakenders and
durs reads like 20 30 pages and he's
like dude I think this is pretty funny I
think you would be funny in this role uh
do it it's a studio movie like hell yeah
yeah and
um it's a job it's a job yeah and and
Blake was like uh-huh
and then we're working late at night and
he comes in by the way he does not
remember doing this he thinks I'm making
this story up
he did this and he comes into my office
and uh or we might have been sharing an
office at that time and he come and but
he comes into the room and he's like hey
dude um
I don't think you should do the movie I
think it's going to ruin all of our
careers
he doesn't remember saying that he
doesn't remember if he totally doesn't
remember saying it but I'm like you
didn't move him uh so then it's like
heavy on me thinking like am I gonna
ruin
not only my career but also my friends
careers that we just finally got careers
after like trying to make it for so long
and then work Alex is like taking off
because you know we're always just like
a cool show you know where like the the
kids who like party and have fun watch
watch our show I don't know if the
acapella crowd necessarily who crosses
over
um but then you know thank God I didn't
listen to and thank God I was willing to
burn all of our careers to the ground
for my own personal gain out of all of
that the craziest piece for me was that
your Bros read a script that was for you
yeah yeah like I can't even read a
script that's for me let alone do it for
my buddies that's friends yeah well like
I said maybe 20 Pages they didn't finish
the damn thing yeah before Pitch Perfect
did you have any like um did you do
anything involving music or singing it
was that first project involving that
kind of stuff and that was the first
thing like I mean I when I told my dad
uh when I told my dad I was like because
it's a studio movie Universal made it so
like
you know that's like kind of a cool
thing to do a movie that did actual I
mean you made it yeah you're in a real
movie that a movie studio is putting out
and how Hollywood works is like you have
to get in the door that way for then uh
so other Studios will look and go like
oh okay I guess he's allowed to be in
movies now you know right uh and so uh
I when I called my parents I was like
I'm gonna be in this movie uh it's Pitch
Perfect not a baseball movie uh it's
Pitch Perfect it's a singing acapella
movie and my dad goes whoa you can't
sing worth [__] and I go yeah I can I
can totally sing he's like no you can't
you [__] suck and I'm like no I don't
you suck yo quit projecting on to me you
are the one that sucks at singing I'm an
okay singer and he still to this day is
like
I don't like it and I'm like all right
well it's not for you okay Vinnie said
that movie's hilarious I love it yeah
yeah I know people I love it dude
especially that first one is a funny one
the first one's the best yes it was a
funny movie it uh no no offense but to
me it was like oh like a movie about
singing like yeah that's so that's how I
went into it too well that dude that's
how I went into shooting it
but I'm like take
I was like so glad I did it because it
was
I did it it was like a runaway hit I
mean it like cost like 15 million to
make and it made like 100 plus million
dollars and then uh and so it's like a
runaway hit they made three of them and
uh I was in the first two and then now
I'm doing I do a spin-off TV show based
on my character from Pitch Perfect
called Bumper in Berlin so like it's
just the gift that keeps on giving and
uh where's that show that's on peacock
okay cool yeah and so I gotta spend I
gotta spend like four months last year
in Berlin just living in Berlin as if
I'm like a cool German guy which uh have
you been to Berlin yeah that's a crazy
city that is that is a wild City
I could tell you're a little guarded
right now you got some Berlin stories
wow
bergkheim put some stuff up your butt
what happened here I'm just waiting like
I went to Berlin on uh the reaper Bond
what was I I was thinking I was
promoting that killer kid karaoke show I
hosted
um I was on a airplane with uh here's
the chick from Pitch Perfect Anna
Kendrick and Kendrick she was on the
flight eight they ate the restroom just
happened to be sitting next to Ryan
Reynolds and uh Anna Kendrick on the
patio at this restaurant and then uh
that night they'd take me to Soho house
that's where I stayed I lived at the
Soho House yeah and and uh and I'm just
sitting here in some house and George
Clooney sits right there like I'm just
like man it's more Hollywood than
Hollywood exactly yeah and and I feel
like a turd for like like saying all
those names but screw it that was my
trip to Berlin I was there for like two
days oh yeah those are the biggest names
in Hollywood yeah right and uh yeah
whatever was going on in Berlin it was a
good weekend to be there yeah it was so
I was there for like four months it's
like it's a truly nut City because like
you're like working there you get to
meet like the the the like just a guy
who goes to work like it's he's like the
grip who just looks like a guy that you
would just know
um but then he's like yeah move excuse
me and he speaks like German you know
and you're like oh [__] this guy uh he
could live in Van Nuys but he lives in
in um Berlin and then you see like at
the Soho House guys that are like about
to go out that night in like full
assless leather chaps with like their
nipples pierced with like a chain
connecting then a chain going down there
and they're like What's that connected
to and uh like that guy's just sitting
there like literally eating rotisserie
chicken like covered in grease just like
eating you're like this guy's just
having a regular night like it was a
wild yeah and everybody speaks English
too like yeah for the most part there's
like no language barrier for us yeah
yeah it's it's not that's it does make
you go like oh I'm America we're such
[__] like no one knows any any other
language they're like I speak French I
speak English obviously I speak German
uh yeah the the whole world is is people
who speak multiple languages and then
there's Americans yeah then there's us
yeah it's it's a crazy there's a club
called uh bear gun which is like
the like techno like electronic music
club and we just went I I was like
that's not really my scene but I kind of
wanted to check it out so like well we
went to like see there was like a line
like four city blocks long to get in of
just like
muscular just jacked dudes all wearing
like Breakaway track suits because for
sure they're just wearing like leather
pouches over their nut sacks uh
underneath there and uh so we didn't go
in it was like the line was crazy and um
I we went to dinner and like one of the
nights and the the clubs had just opened
it up because it was covered times and
they were like I'm talking to the the
maitre d and our table was getting ready
and he goes ah you liking Berlin I'm
like oh it's cool and he goes the club's
just open have you been to the clubs I'm
like oh no and he goes oh bear climbing
got to go it's so crazy the piss parties
and
I guess there's a guy
at Bear time who's been there for like
30 years he's like a staple he's like 60
years old now and he's just like spent
his whole adult life at this at the bear
come getting pissed on they call him the
piss Goblin and you'll be like pissing
in the like trough uh in the men's
bathroom and he'll just like lay in
there
so and that's so group trip let's take
this let's get that
let's get the wild ride over to Berlin
man yeah they make schizen movies there
too what are schizen moves schizen is a
German for [__]
what kind of [__] movies we talking I
mean I think it's like I think I've been
in a few [__]
yeah
um yeah I mean whatever
okay yeah
um so uh how much stand-up are you doing
these days though not enough I was like
I I just was talking about this I uh so
I did my my special and uh the end of 18
and then I was like kind of burnt out
because I was doing so much acting work
and then to try to also do stand up at
the same time and give it the like
because you really should be going out
all the time to like stay sharp and I
just felt like I wasn't giving it enough
and I was like I think I'm gonna take a
little break just do some acting stuff
and then in 2020 get back to it and then
you know the pandemic hit and uh and
then as soon as I got back from the
pandemic it was like like for the past
two years I uh I was home a total of
like five or six weeks in two years like
where you just like calm you touch your
stuff and then you could leave again
because you got somewhere else to be so
um but right now it's like the
workholics movie was canceled and then
this strike hit and so now I should be
going out but I'm just being a lazy sack
of [__] but all my friends like come
down come to the The Improv or The
Comedy Store like I'll give you a spot
I'm like
yeah
what time is that they're like 8 30 and
I'm like oh yeah
I like to be uh Stoned on my couch at 8
30. so uh I don't know uh bar are you
are you out there out and about yeah
dude I've been touring my dick off
that's sick yeah I'm actually I do miss
it it's something so fun about uh just
being on stage and making people laugh
like in the moment as opposed to you
know you do a movie or whatever and you
gotta wait months to hear them yeah
especially on Netflix you're like you
you're like are they laughing you know
you're just like looking online and you
know sometimes people are nice online
but for the most part people are like
does Adam DeVine have Down syndrome
that's like the main uh
uh yeah so it's not uh yeah you know you
never you don't get that same thing that
you do from standing up yeah I love it
man I've got my whole thing with uh the
multimedia comedy so yeah yeah I know
that's sick I filmed forbidden things
and then uh make an act out of it and
pay off the bits with the footage of the
that's fond dude yeah that's so fun yeah
I remember when you first started to
show up around the clubs it was cool to
see well thanks man yeah
I I I I remember seeing you in in clubs
too man it's uh it's fun that's and
that's also what I miss about doing
stand-up is like the camaraderie like
actors don't have the same level of
camaraderie like if you see another
actor who you kind of know you like will
be like at a restaurant or whatever but
but it's like comics
even if you don't know that other comic
you just sort of like gravitate towards
them at a party and be like
because you know you're kind of the
misfit weirdo and you're just you're
like I guess we'll be friends today and
it's nice when you're in a weird City or
not even weird City just a random City
you know that you can go to the comedy
club and and that's home base that could
be home base no matter what so I missed
that uh that sense of community for sure
it it sure can have you been uh in touch
with with your boy Zac Efron
yeah dude that he hit me up like two
weeks ago Zach is like
I mean he's he's all over the place this
guy and I haven't seen him in years and
I you know I haven't even really talked
to him within that long and he hit me up
and he was like dude uh I'm sorry I've
been M.I.A let's hang out more and I'm
like hell yeah dude let's hang out
obviously and then he was like
I got a favor to ask and I'm like okay
and he goes can I live with you for two
weeks this is just like a month ago he's
asked if he could live with me and I was
like oh yeah all right man yeah come on
down I would love to have you yeah like
[__] let's let's party I I you know I
love Zach and uh and then he's like
awesome I'll hit you up tomorrow I guess
he had like bought a house but it wasn't
closing he couldn't get the keys for a
few weeks or something and uh and he was
like yeah let's uh let's hang out and
then I'm like all right and then he goes
I'll hit you up in a couple days and
we'll figure out a plan I'm like great
so I tell my wife and then my wife is
like Zac Efron's gonna live with us and
so she's like washing like triple
washing machines and you know you're
cleaning like a mad woman I'm like our
house is perfectly fine for a guest and
uh and then didn't hear back from him
okay he was on his way to your house and
he stopped off at a poker game
he was just parked and was like
um
he was in Australia wasn't he like just
like like years he moved there
permanently yeah yeah I know we yeah I
know he loves Australia we we did uh a
press tour of Mike and Dave need wedding
dates in Australia and he just like it
was just like home for him and so he was
like I'm gonna live here one day and
then sure enough like he just up and
decided to move to Australia which is
so cool not something that I would ever
do but I love the fact I love people
that are just willing to be like and now
I live here
right dude I was just saying it popped
in my head as a random question and I
had no idea that the answer was going to
be that fascinating yeah well it
wouldn't have been April you would have
asked me like two months ago I would
have been like yeah I didn't really
talked with him for a couple years like
other than like a random text here and
there but yeah it was like he facetimed
me and he was like
in the Bahamas at some like Golf Resort
he was just like I'm really into golf
lately and then he sends me a video of
him like doing a Chip Shot he's like I'm
like that's great yeah
um okay so uh YouTube video recently
that said that there's some really
seedy like uh crazy duto
world of yachting
yacht like the dark side of yachting
being a oh [__] luxury Yachts what's the
dark side of it the dark side I've been
on a yada I thought it was pretty
[__] cool
Brandon see the dark side yeah
against the ultra-rich people yeah on
the yachts and they like hire all kinds
of models to to get on the yacht and
it's understood that model's gonna put
out oh for sure that has to be so it's
like basically like and and then this
this this YouTube video about the Dark
Side of yachting like suggested that
it's been alleged that like all kinds of
like high level like like uh yeah it's
international waters you know I'm like
acting as anything can happen out there
like maybe like doing some favors for
some dough like and and the the even the
it's it's uh suggested that this is a
way into the entertainment industry it's
got to go on this Yachts get paid a
little bit do some favors
something strange well [__] man I'm
trying to go on this yeah
fantastic yeah
start to think that all these pictures
we see of Leonardo Dicaprio and Yachts
that he might be getting some action on
there
I don't think I think those girls would
want to [__] Leo regardless of whether
he's on a yacht or not but uh yeah I
know the I just went on like an awesome
trip
um my friend Nina Dobrev who I'm in the
Outlaws with it was her birthday and
they they got like a yacht in Indonesia
and I went to Indonesia and like spent
some time but there weren't any hookers
on there so it was a different vibe much
different you know it was just like uh
friends hanging out yeah yeah Indonesia
is the yacht's like 12 bucks out there
yeah it was it was a little cheaper than
in the Bahamas I've looked into it I was
like I came back and I was like yeah
maybe I'm a yacht guy because it was
like the best vacation I've ever been on
versus so you're on a boat and they're
constantly like giving you little snacks
and like handing you a drink and you're
like this is my kind of vacation and
then I like was like I'm gonna I'm gonna
be a yacht guy like because I have a big
birthday coming up I turn 40 years old
this year so I'm like you know what I'm
gonna like maybe I get a yacht for my
40th birthday and then I looked up how
much Yachts cough and I'm like maybe I'm
not a yacht guy yeah yeah yeah maybe I'm
like a nice hotel for a weekend type of
guy yeah Scott just turned 40. yeah yeah
I was uh I looked on the beignet that's
what I get cars or seasick as [__] oh
really I can't even deal yeah but I
sailed around New Zealand and I it was
okay because you just vomited for no no
that was Alaska but like the way they
did it was the guy picks you up and you
just kind of like hang out in little
Bays all day yeah and then you go to the
next Bay and you go to the next Bay but
yeah that's kind of how Indonesia was it
was cool I had never been there it was
like the most beautiful place I'd ever
been I'm sure New Zealand is wildly
beautiful but it was like uh there's so
many islands that it like there's no
like break there's no like waves
anywhere so it was just like a lake with
Crystal Blue Water Everywhere it was rad
Indonesia they have killer waves well
not where I was yeah but I'm sure
there's like if you go on the outside of
the islands there's like a sick breaks
but like where we were I was like this
is like the flattest that had they taken
you to a [__] and break would you have
been shrop in it uh no dude I suck at
surfing like I'm the worst uh what does
Trope mean okay okay
uh no I suck dude I'm like because I I
have a place down in uh Orange County so
I'm like right on the beach and I'm like
I'm gonna be a surfer like all my
friends are Surfers it's so hard dude I
suck so bad and they're all so good so
like they don't even want to teach me
they're like over they're like
figure it out and I'm like I'm trying
and it's just miserable for me so and
yeah and I'm a liability in the water
yeah just causing crashes and you you
can't slap
I mean sometimes like I can catch a wave
and ride it okay yeah but it's just such
a strong can you are you a skateboarder
can you yeah yeah that's what I thought
yeah and if that doesn't transfer I I'm
definitely it does not transfer oh
skating does not transfer to surgery
once you're up you're good it's just
catching the wave yeah and dunk diving
you know but now you you seem to be like
really fit like yeah I wore my tied a
shirt for this interview yeah
I gotta let you guys know are you are
you just hitting the gym are you not
well yeah uh but I uh no I I like tore
my groin doing that Pitch Perfect show
the bumper in Berlin okay and then since
then I've had all kinds of issues with
like my groin on my back and like so I
can't uh I used to like recycle a lot
and ride back to how did you tear your
groin just doing a Fantastical kick
just like giving it my all with like the
giant John Claude Van Damme totally dude
I like just kicked up it's so silly it
was just like the goofiest thing of me
just like wiggling around and I just
went like with my leg and I felt like
and I'm in Germany and it was like day
two of shooting the show so and I'm the
lead and so I needed to be singing and
dancing for every goddamn episode so
they just gave me pain pills and so it
was me just chewing pain pills and like
gritting through it thinking like it
would heal on its own it didn't cost a
lot of other issues so it kind of [__]
everything up so now like I can't work
out in the way I was used to I used to
like ride a bike all the time and it
kind of made me like
skinny you know lean right like a lean
muscle and certain I have to like do
something every day because I have like
all this energy and I gotta get it out
somewhere uh and so I like have just
been lifting weights now I'm getting
jacked as [__] dude yeah yeah dude my my
lady told me like I think she said this
yesterday she said she saw something
which
it's it's sad
if you take a cigarette smoker pack a
day smoker who
exercises
and put them next to a non-smoker
somebody who's never ever smoked who
does not exercise
smokers going to live longer and a
healthier life wait why because not
exercising where did she read this not
exercising is worse for you than smoking
yeah I guess well if unless you get lung
cancer and die but uh yeah yeah it
sounds us I feel like there's I
there's some Nuance there but I I do
think like
having some level of blood flow of yeah
of exercise whether it's like my parents
um that has been a while ago now like
five maybe like seven years ago now
something like that but they lost like
50 and 60 pounds each wow and just just
like that and they like were never they
never really worked out their whole
lives and then they just uh uh someone
said that they looked like chicken
nuggets and they were like well it's
time to start working out wow and uh
they started working out and they
dropped all this weight and uh yeah
they're like healthier looking than
they've ever been and they're just like
I think it's so important and they don't
really do that crazy stuff it's like
they just kind of go on like long walks
every day and like yeah maybe eat a
little less yeah eat yeah eat a little
healthier it's also easier to eat a
little healthier when you do work out
because they're like well I worked out I
shouldn't maybe I shouldn't eat this
like Twinkie or the candy bar you know
before you're like I just worked out I
deserve for Twinkie yeah but you were
gonna eat that Twinkie regardless yeah
here's a qualifier for for uh what luck
saw and what she told me about with the
smoking and and this is something that
Vinnies had affected him pretty pretty
deeply
um
you see old people really old people
smoking away all the time
you never see really old super obese
people no you sure don't yeah
so I went to Chipotle today and I like
ordered some tacos and I was eating and
I looked around and everybody in there
was like super overweight and just threw
it away and left is that right I did
uh well I just saw like a thing and who
knows how real it is because it's like
on the internet so who knows it might be
like this study that who knows
but but it was it was like a guy who I
mean was a big guy but it was like 1909
or 1916 like something a long time ago
and he was like a big guy
but not bigger than other people that
you know you know like I have family
members that are like just as big as as
this guy and it said that he was the
world's fattest man at that time wow and
you're like that guy was the big it just
goes to show like all the processed all
the uh
the 3D printed chicken
well I think people were like they said
the average person in the Civil War was
like five nine 130 pounds
and like a bunch of like people from
2023 were to go fight in the Civil War
we'd kick their asses yeah yeah average
man was just tinier you know oh yeah
it's like it's like if you have a and
like an like our especially our house uh
down in Orange County it's like a 1920s
beach cottage and like the doors are
like super skinny everything's like tiny
and like you're just like oh yeah this
is people were so [__] small back
then I'm not a big guy but I'm like uh
I'm like I'm a giant man in this house
you know did the fattest person in the
world I'm just thinking they've got that
my 600 pound life show and there's no
shortage of cast members for that so oh
yeah but whoever's the fattest person in
the world has to be like in the
thousands of pounds no thousands maybe
like maybe one thousand yeah one
thousand she's three thousand pounds
this is where we need uh like a Jamie
who's bringing up bring it up and have
it on the computer the screen right here
yeah for sure yeah dude I think it's
time to level up our game dude and
become a little bit more multimedia
let's do it yeah it's like your show
dude it's time
multimedia the Pod have it if you sit
here I'm decent singer have made music
do you have like uh no I haven't really
I it's I and I I might really enjoy
doing it I just uh
I haven't no I mean I I do things for
the show and I do things for the Pitch
Perfect movies but uh
but no I I you know I'm so concentrated
on like what I'm doing like getting
movies off the ground doing the Outlaws
that movie trying to set up that thing
like
I'm trying to write a book right now so
like trying to get that off the ground
just like all all that other stuff I'm
like it's just another creative Endeavor
on the plate which I probably it
probably would just be like a fun thing
to do how like Seth Rogen got into
Pottery it's like he doesn't need to be
like a professional Pottery guy but he
like likes enjoys doing it it's like ah
[__] I like doing this so yeah I might I
might land instruments no that's so
that's my Achilles heel I just can't uh
yeah I I don't I don't play [__] what
would you play you could I played the
drums a little bit as a kid but then my
parents I I only learned One Beat and my
parents were like weren't selling it
we're selling your drum kit because it's
just me going
for like hours and it wouldn't change it
up it'd just be me just [__] getting
that beat down my dad's like [__] stop
and also we lived in like a 1500 square
foot house so my parents were like
you know you meet some actors that are
like wildly talented that are like I
could tap dance I could ride the piano I
can sing I can I speak two languages or
three languages you know and I'm I'm
wildly untalented I only can do a couple
things but I I just think that you're
great man you're cute man yeah dude
there's my Maynard moment with Adam
DeVine
I I I'm just absolutely riveted by the
righteous gemstones thanks man and uh if
anybody hasn't seen it you are blowing
it it's it's fun it's really fun show
and the Outlaws sounds like really
hysterical I think yeah I think you'd
really like it check it out when it
comes out July 7th on on Netflix who are
they and why is the Pierce Brosnan and
uh Ellen Barkin so it's it's fun dude
yeah all right Netflix The Outlaws
that's right and as this comes out on
July 6th we're talking tomorrow yep
midnight tonight midnight tonight
yeah and and it's got it you gotta watch
it right away at first you gotta give
that that initial boost
that's yeah it is it's it's cool Netflix
uh it is amazing their algorithm like
really pushes it to people so and we did
it with uh Adam Sandler's company so
happy Madison and so uh that they just
really know how to make movies it was so
impressive to like work with them
because they they we had like five guys
around the monitors just pitching jokes
nice which I was like which was so nice
to take because when me and the work
always guys make a movie it's like it's
us yeah and it's like it just takes a
lot of the pressure off to go like so
your brain isn't constantly like in a
scene going like and what and thinking
of things that doors can say and think
of the things that Blake could say it's
like you could concentrate on your
performance and then go back to the
Brain Trust take three ideas and go oh
yeah I'm gonna try that one and then run
and go do it it was super fun
well right on man
success thanks dudes yeah man
I'm not even gonna try yeah
anything that you wanna uh like cut out
like
if and if anything more butthole talk
yeah
foreign
how about that man do we love this guy
or what and how about the fact that I'm
sitting here in London England with my
crazy dog that I found at this shelter
in a town called Hull the dog's
attacking other dogs people like my my
girl
all right I'm gonna start that over yeah
I already said the dog's been attacking
everybody in an ad read earlier
three two one
how about that man choose the episode
right can you believe the Zac Efron
stuff can you believe the hater age
stuff talking about man
I uh just was glad that it was it was so
entertaining and I'm glad that you're
here at the very end so that I can tell
you again I'm in London it's the first
time this is the first time we've ever
done adreads just with the love Mike
I mean it's crazy I think that I never
want to use
uh the handheld mic stand
you know if this sounds good maybe let
us know how how did the ad reads in this
outro in the intro with this microphone
sound I don't know and uh again I'm in
London I'm having a great trip I might
get arrested tomorrow I'm just saying
wish me luck love you